In Japan, Prime Minister Shinzo Abe announced his government has chosen the name "Reiwa"...
...to represent the reign of Emperor Akihito's son, Crown Prince Naruhito,...
...who will take the throne on May 1.
In Peru, officials say at least 20 people were killed...
...when a double-decker bus burst into flames in the capital, Lima.
In Turkey, President Recep Tayyip Erdogan's ruling AKP party...
...loses control of the capital, Ankara, in local elections,...
...in what is seen as a blow for his 16-year rule of the country.
In Ukraine, citizens react after the first round of presidential elections...
...as actor and comedian Volodymyr Zelensky topped the first round...
...with nearly twice the vote share of his nearest rival, incumbent President Petro Poroshenko.
Finally from Britain, Prime Minister Theresa May...
...faces a new set of votes on Brexit deals, including an April 12 deadline.